[Music]
Princess Merida is a Disney fan favorite
she's the opposite of everything most
princesses stand for and we love her for
it if you wanted to look into Merida's
life after her movie ends we're here to
give it to you you won't believe who we
think Merida walks down the aisle with
stick around to find out who if this is
your first time visiting the things
smash that subscribe button don't forget
to give this video a thumbs up now this
is what happened to Merida after happily
ever after brave is one of the most
groundbreaking Disney original stories
it gave us the very first princess who
isn't obsessed with marriage or falling
in love being boy crazy isn't all there
is to life Merida knows she's fine on
her own she's also completely unafraid
to turn her nose up at typical princess
stuff she's not a fan of fluffy dresses
fancy parties or other girly stuff she's
a rough-and-tumble warrior she spent her
childhood wrestling with her father and
little brothers - she loves her horse
Angus and works very hard to take care
of him
Disney creators even wrote a scene
showing Merida mucking out his stall
herself they wanted to demonstrate just
how different she was from other
princesses she's not afraid of a little
hard work or manure she's also a master
of archery not too many other princesses
can say they're a master with a weapon
Mulan could probably hold her own
against her maybe that's why she has so
many fans shipped the two together
relationships aren't really her thing
though the best thing about Merida is
her independence she isn't afraid of
being alone she can depend on herself
when her family precious hard to get
married she sticks up for her freedom
well I'm not going to be like you she
wants to wait until she's ready to
commit and settle down she won't marry
for political convenience and she wants
to marry for love to a modern person
that sounds really smart and responsible
in 10th century Scotland it was madness
women were expected to do as they were
told
can you picture Merida as obedient we
didn't think so she was way ahead of her
time so we know she's the best at the
end of the film her family members are
restored to their true forms and
everyone seems happy then what happens
since she won't be getting married
anytime soon Merida needs something to
fill her time she can't just spend her
life cooped up in the castle
she's not the type to sit around and
broad rain until the end of time to keep
herself busy
Merida begins a school for girls instead
of teaching them etiquette or ballroom
dancing Merida teaches them really
valuable skills horseback riding archery
and public speaking are the basics she
spends her days building strong women
out of all the girls in the kingdom she
encourages them not to get married just
because they're told it's time she wants
them to wait until they're truly in love
and ready with her small army of little
girls Merida delights in terrorizing the
kingdom with practice raids and warrior
games we love imagining her crazy grin
as she rides Angus ahead of her tiny
troops a horde of little Scottish girls
riding sheep and wielding toy swords and
bow and arrows is nothing to mess with
you wouldn't hear of mini girls being
bullied in this kingdom they'd even
stick up for the boys she hasn't gotten
her newfound respect for bears either
before her mother and little brothers
were transformed bears were seen as a
barbaric enemy in the kingdom now that
Merida has spent so much time getting to
know the species she sees them as so
much more her experience inspires her to
give bears a PR makeover she launches a
public education campaign to teach her
people all about these misunderstood
creatures they aren't just vicious
beasts out for blood
bears are generally pretty peaceful and
laid-back they prefer to stay away from
people and live quiet lives Merida helps
people see that bears aren't evil
monsters bent on their destruction with
the public's less afraid of their fury
Brown neighbors their hunting begins to
decline people become less fearful they
don't see any reason to aggressively
hunt down these magnificent creatures
anymore with the important first step in
place Merida begins an a a conversation
program it's not enough to reduce how
many bears are killed Merida wants to
ensure that there will be bears in
Scotland for future generations to enjoy
she's spearheads a program to limit the
number of bears that can be killed
protect areas where bears live with
their young and even track breeding
season to ensure a healthy population
she teaches this respect for bears to
her students as well with those fearless
ladies as their guardians the Bears of
Scotland are safe no one is going to
mess with them anytime soon Merida is a
princess which means one day she'll be
queen the
way for that to happen is sadly for her
and her brothers to lose their mom and
dad that does sad fact of inheriting a
throne death is inevitable and
eventually the king and queen would both
pass away leaving Merida to rule after
their deaths there would be a grand
coronation for Princess Merida this
would be a pretty important moment for
her not only would she become Queen
during this ceremony but the days before
and after would establish what kind of
leader she would be she would probably
face more pressure to get married an
unwed female leader was a rare thing in
her time but Merida would hold her
ground he wouldn't be forced to marry as
a young woman so she certainly wouldn't
be forced as a confident Queen much like
the archery contests in the movie Merida
comes up with a clever plan to silence
her suitors this time instead of
fighting for her own hand she's going to
take it these days a lot of women have
jumped on to the newest trend in
marriage brides no longer find a groom
necessary and they've been marrying
themselves that's right
one person marriage is a new trend this
very modern fad is perfect for our
Merida she refused to marry just for
political convenience she only wants to
marry someone she truly loves and find
love in our own time Merida is the kind
of person who would only choose someone
she could respect someone she saw as her
true equal who fits that bill better
than herself she's someone truly worthy
of her own love and admiration she
obviously holds herself and high esteem
so to stop the pressure for her to find
a husband Merida decides to marry
herself solo weddings can be just as
beautiful meaningful and ornate as a
traditional ceremony Merida is a rock
star Queen and she doesn't need a king
to be happy imagine the excitement when
the royal wedding is announced people
would freak out gossip would fly about
who the lucky man is people would wonder
why the groom's identity was being kept
so quiet the wedding would have to be
fit for a queen no expense would be
spared for the extravagant affair even
Angus would be dressed to the nines his
mane and tail braided flowers in his
hair the handsome horse would really be
a showstopper The Triplets wouldn't be
forgotten there that would be sure to
have plenty of sweets on hand for her
three favorite young men for once they
would all be clean well-dressed and at
the peak of their manners on the big day
nobility would gather from all of the
clans to see Merida walk down the aisle
each suspecting a man from another clan
must be the lucky groom the castle would
be totally decked out with flowers
banners and finery at the end of the
fabric and petal lined Isle stands the
officiant
he's giddy to participate in the wedding
of a queen bagpipes play as Queen Merida
in a stunning white gown enters the hall
she confidently takes slow metered steps
toward the officiant waiting at the end
by now everyone is in shock they've
caught on that there is no groom but
none of them could ever be prepared for
what was to come next at the end of her
bridal procession Merida clears her
throat and proudly announces that she's
decided on the only person worthy enough
for her to marry herself all of her
guests would be stunned none would know
how to react the reception would be full
of blank pale faces the triplets would
be delighted by their sister's stunning
display they would dance with her with
joy and celebrate her fierce
independence obviously the ceremony
wouldn't be a legally binding shindig it
would just be a lavish symbol to her
subjects that her martial status was no
longer up for discussion with her
wedding behind there it's time for
Merida to get her Kingdom and order
there's so much change to be made might
our young people decide for themselves
who they will love the Queen's
frustration with the way women are
treated in her kingdom would inspire
sweeping reform she would make it
illegal to refuse any interested woman
from participating in the Highland Games
she knows that women are just as strong
and capable as men Queen Merida would
also overhaul marriage laws ensuring
that both husbands and wives had equal
rights and responsibilities she'd be the
first rulers make marriage a true 50/50
partnership with women on equal footing
with men her Kingdom would be twice as
prosperous and happy it's obvious to
anyone who's seen the film that Meredith
loves kids the way she treats her baby
brothers makes it clear that she thinks
of children as her peers
in being so much older she never treats
them like they aren't people this love
of children would eventually lead Merida
to want to become a mother without a
husband she probably wouldn't have any
natural children of her own
like any liberated woman being single
isn't going to stop our Queen from
becoming a parent Merida decides to
adopt a child she needs to make sure her
child will be legally recognized as an
heir should something happen to her and
her brothers those details could all be
worked out when you're a queen you can
afford any amounts of legal help she's
not afraid of anything being a single
mom to more than one child wouldn't face
her at all she already grew up with
triplets so a set of twins would be
nothing to the brave Queen with her mind
made up and the legal work out of the
way Merida chooses her children isn't it
fun to picture her with two cute little
kids in tow a little boy who she teaches
to cure women's voices a little girl who
she teaches to speak up for herself her
children would be royalty that probably
means they'd be spoiled just a little
but with a mom like Merida they
definitely learned the value of hard
work her kids would work in the stables
as she did they would help the castle
staff with chores her daughter would be
a very skilled Archer and her son a
talented horse trainer they would grow
to be compassionate and responsible
Royals they would go on to embrace their
own independence and find love in their
own time marry that would joyfully
celebrate her children's marriages
especially her daughters who would
choose her partner carefully and only
after she was ready as time passed
Merida would welcome grandchildren into
the kingdom as well with so much love
and family to share her life Merida
would be a happy and fulfilled Queen
Merida deserves nothing but the best
after she courageously saves her family
from life as Bears she goes on serving
her people he teaches the young women of
her kingdom to be proud and strong the
belief that you can save them yourself
she shares her love of archery with the
people she rules over she protects her
ancestral lands and the animals that
called him home she's ahead of her time
in so many ways she turns her peoples
opinions of bears around with the power
of her words and compassion she shows
her people what it means to choose
yourself over tradition the women of her
kingdom enjoy unprecedented rights and
freedoms she chooses motherhood for her
self and raises strong and respectful
children Merida truly is a leader worth
our fandom she really did live happily
ever after
we hoped you like seeing past the
credits of brave we'll see you next time
on the things
[Music]